good morning John you left me in
Missoula and I forgive you but I don't
know if you're gonna forgive yourself
because this weekend Katherine and I
went hiking in the Bitterroot Valley and
we came across a hatch of butterflies
it's probably safe to say that
Lepidoptera is the most beloved order of
insects just generally think of insects
as creepy
bitey sting II gross ugly yucky bugs and
then you have butterflies and people
like beg to be covered in toad - bugs on
me no other bug does this work for
Lepidoptera is the order that contains
butterflies and moths and you might
recognize Optra
from pterodactyl and ornithopter leopard
though you probably don't recognize
comes from the word for scales and that
doesn't necessarily make sense to you
except butterfly that scales all the
NASA guy who named the order Lepidoptera
also the guy who came up with the
current system that we have for naming
species
if you're curious important dude looked
at butterflies in a microscope and said
oh my god they're freaking covered in
scale that's crazy and that's a direct
quote from his journal that's crazy when
I was in grade school I told this to a
kid named Li said butterflies have
scales in their wings and if you touch
them the scales will rub off and they
will die that was like that's ridiculous
look the butterfly has no scales and I
was like no they're microscopic you'd
have to and then he punched me true
story
Martinus can be intimidating some people
punch in response to intimidation so let
that be a lesson to us all stop being
smart most of the tens of thousands I'm
pretty sure of butterflies we saw were
Western whites we also saw a bunch of
other species but most of them by far
were the Western whites and western ones
are very common they look pretty much
the gotta the same as chequered whites
if you have chequered whites where you
live the only difference between
chequered whites and Western whites is
that Western whites live in mountains
and chequered whites live and the plains
the other difference there's two is that
they have incompatible genitalia
lepidopterists people who study
butterflies
sounds like a nice beautiful job mostly
they spend their time staring at
butterfly genitalia no it's the only
reliable way to differentiate between
species so if you think about switching
your career path to lepidopterist just
know that a lot of butterfly genitalia
in your future look at the before is
still the butterflies make you think oh
wow maybe think a lot things and
everything about bell curves and how at
one point there will be one butterfly
left alive in that forest and at one
point there was only one adult butterfly
that had hatched and in between it's a
curve but at that very edge part
it was what made me wonder whether
people can still care about nature if
they don't get the opportunities that I
have to go out and experience it and see
how amazing it is and then on the court
of them I notice all the rose petals on
the water and I thought that was weird
there's not a lot of flowering plants
right now I wonder what all those petals
are from and then I realized those are
not flower petals those are butterflies
just like our economy goes through booms
and busts so to do the economies of
nature so to do that grammatically
correct doesn't sound like it but I
think it is there were so many
butterflies in the forest that every
predator was full the chipmunks which
don't even eat butterflies were eating
butterflies because they're everywhere
chickadees were so full they could
hardly fly the spider webs were torn
apart by butterflies way more
butterflies than any spider could ever
eat bees bees were attacking butterflies
I didn't know they did this I saw it
happen attack it butterfly chew off its
wings and then fly away with the body
and there were some bees that didn't
even bother chewing off the wings and
they would fly away with the whole
butterfly making it look like this dead
butterfly unmoving dead butterfly was
flying away it was very strange when I
started to notice the dead butterflies
everywhere that's when I started
thinking about the main thing that I
thought about on this side the energy
that makes it all happen the energy of
the Sun passing into plants passing into
caterpillars passing into butterflies
passing into bees passing into spiders
into birds until finally the energy has
let loose again it's free again to
dissipate into the universe as energy
wants to do some days it seems to me
like the purpose of life is to convert
energy into beauty and I know that
that's not true I know that that's not
rationally true but some days it's okay
for things to not be rationally true
John I will see you on Monday